I wanted to get your perspective it's
something that everyone's been talking
about and rightfully so the last year
how much things are changing for women
now and and you came up in this era that
was quite different for women comedy
back in the covered wagon days yeah was
different I see when I was going to do
my show I had a contract with CBS which
was very unusual that said that if I
wanted to push the button they would
have to put on an hour like comedy
variety show with me
up for 30 shows Wow maybe a whole season
you had leverage and you could do that
if you wanted where they were they happy
about that no they when they first get
the contract well you know was like five
or ten years before that and then I
decided to push the button and when I
called them to say you know like I want
to do that they said what are you
talking about they've forgotten about
that contract now why did they not want
you variable comedian to do comedy
variety well when I said I want to do
that show they said oh well Carol you
knew comedy variety is a man's game said
it's Jackie Gleason it said Caesar no it
was Dean Martin and the vice-president
that I was talking to said you know
Carol it's not for you gals he said but
we have this great sitcom we'd love you
to do called here's Agnes
[Laughter]
oh wait a minute I got offered that same
sitcom I hope you turned it down no I
want to do Agnes I don't want to be the
same character every week I want to do
different characters I want to have
music and guest stars in a rep company
and you know costumes and we had a
28-piece Orchestra double dancers I mean
it was just you you know the I think
what's amazing in the climate we're in
now and and this is the way things
should be if someone said no comedies
just is not for you gals that's better
now I mean that would be a hundred
billion dollar lawsuit right just keep
saying that this was a time when that
was something a person and an executive
felt very comfortable saying on the
telephone yes he yes he was and you know
and I kind of understood it because
that's where I was raised thinking that
you know and but then I said but that's
not what I want to do and in fact that I
had that contract I wouldn't be sitting
here now talking to you like this yeah
wouldn't have happened all right I've
come over to your house I've gone
anywhere to talk to you so
you